Raman: Hello, everyone.
I am T.V. Raman
and this
is my officemate
Charles Chen.
And we hack together,
code together,
so we
also talk together.
Hopefully not
at the same time
and hopefully
the phone won't talk
while the two
of us are talking too.
This talk is about building
eyes-free interfaces on Android.
We are calling it,
"looking beyond the screen."
That doesn't mean
you hold your phone like this
and look at the world
over it.
It's basically building
user interfaces
that go over
and beyond the screen.
This talk is structured
into two halves
where the first half I'd like
to walk you through
some of the thought processes
we went through
in terms of coming up
with some
of the UI paradigms
we are trying out.
And in the second
half of the talk,
Charles will sort of
walk you through
some of the libraries
we are open-sourcing
that actually allow
you to bring
some of this UI code
into your own applications.
So let's start
working through
the media sections
of this talk.
The first section
of this talk,
I'd like to focus
on what it means
to sort of be someone
who does UI research
and UI implementations
in the mobile world,
because I believe this
is distinctly different
from the last 35 years of
human-computer interaction
that has gone before.
And you'll sort of see
why I think that
in the next few slides.
But we are all geeks here.
We are developers here.
Let's sort of celebrate
our geekdom for a minute
by sort of looking at that phone
that we all have
and understanding why that's
an engineer's dream.
Obviously, that phone
is more powerful
than the desktop workstation
I had 20 years ago,
15 years ago.
Obviously, this thing can do
a lot more
because it's connected
to the network.
Those are enablers.
Now the third enabler
that you have, obviously,
is building cool
user interfaces
that help surface all this
coolness to the end users
so that they can
actually use it.
So in that sense,
what does it mean to build
innovative user interfaces
for the mobile world?
Let's ask the question,
"what is a user interface?"
first.
I didn't include that particular
slide in this talk,
but many years ago,
I used to carry around a slide
that is a very simple slide
that sort of explained
what I thought of
as a user interface.
If you pull up very specific
implementations
of a user interface,
such as a GUI,
such as
the next Windows desktop,
a Windows desktop,
a Mac UI,
there is something fundamentally
simple about the UI
It's about human-computer
interaction
as Kai will tell you.
But then that again
has become a buzzword.
So there's the human
and there's the computer.
What is this interaction
we are talking about?
The human-computer interaction
that makes up
the user interface is
really about two things.
It's you, the human,
communicating your intent
to the machine,
the machine computing
on that intent,
and coming up with some answer
and grabbing your attention.
So I used to draw
a little diamond
with a human
on one vertex,
the computer
on another vertex
and sort of
draw arrows saying,
"intention, attention,
input, and output."
So from you goes
input to the machine
to convey your intentions.
Comes back as output
and attention.
And so if you take that view
of user interaction,
UIs that you build
have to fit
into the user's
mode of working,
not the other way around.
So this is about bending
technology to our will.
And an open platform,
especially
in the mobile world,
is extremely conducive
to doing that,
because now the only thing
that blocks, limits
how much you can hack
is your imagination.
So you have all
of the peripherals you want.
You have way more peripherals
than what we've had in the past.
And that's one of
the most important things
about doing mobile
user interfaces.
Let's talk--
go to the next slide
about eyes-free
interaction.
So clearly there are many,
many cool things you can do
as you innovate
along the UI access.
The specific thing that Charles
and I had been focusing on
is using these phones
without looking at them.
No, this is not just about
the blind user.
This is more to say,
"how do you use these devices
"if you are not capable of,
willing to,
or not in a position
to look at the screen?"
And that completely
changes your perspective
on how you build
such things.
Those situations
are obviously many.
You might be driving.
You might be walking
along the corridor
talking to your friends.
There are many situations where
you do not want
to hold your phone
like this and squint at it.
A couple of weeks ago,
I was walking down
one of the corridors at Google
with my guide dog
and my dog suddenly swerved,
and I asked Charles
what happened and he said,
"That was a lucky save.
Somebody almost
walked into you."
I said, "That was
an interesting response," right?
It wasn't,
"I walked into someone."
It was somebody
almost walked into me.
Well, the reason somebody
almost walked into me
was that person was holding
their cell phone
like this
doing email.
This is not safe, right?
I mean, cell phones aren't just
a hazard when you're driving.
I mean, if you start using
cell phones like this,
you need to get tickets
when you're walking too.
So how do you avoid that?
[laughter]
So I think
eyes-free interaction
is really about fitting
into the user's life.
Technology has to sort of
come to that point
where we are able
to do that.
So let's sort of go
to the next slide
and ask what is so cool
about these new phones
that let you do
all these things.
One reason I believe
that sort of the GUI
hasn't really evolved beyond
what Xerox PARC built
in the late '70s is that
the peripherals available
to the GUI designer have not
evolved since then.
Doug Engelbart
invented the mouse,
PARC invented
the bitmap screen,
and the rest is history.
And sadly,
history is all you've had
in that the GUI
has not changed.
Yes, people have worked on how
to layout menus better.
People have learned
how to cram more things
into that limited real estate.
But the fundamental peripherals
with which you interact
with the graphical
user interface
have not changed.
Look at that phone
and count out the peripherals
versus what your laptop has.
Your laptop has a display,
a monitor, a mouse,
a microphone and a speaker,
and perhaps a webcam.
Those latter three,
the microphone,
the speaker,
and the webcam,
are actually quite awkward
to use on a laptop.
Especially the laptop.
Look at your camera.
Look at your phone.
It's a camera.
It's a keyboard.
It's all of these things.
But now think of it
not as all those devices,
but think of it as your computer
in your pocket
with the ability
to sense the world
and see how many more ways
it can sense the world
as opposed to your laptop.
Simple example.
There is a, you know,
mobile scavenger hunt
being announced today.
There is a piece of paper
stuck on the wall
with a QR code.
You can just walk past it,
point your phone at it,
get a URL,
and start browsing.
Isn't that cool?
That's because your phone
has many eyes
and many ears by which
it can sense the world.
And the more it can
sense the world,
the better position
your phone has
with respect to getting
a handle on your intent,
on your intention
as a user.
And the cool thing
about building
mobile user interfaces--
and this may be
a little contradictory
to someone who does
user interfaces
as their
be-all, end-all goal--
is you actually minimize
user interaction.
So in the desktop world
it was always cool
to make the user interact
and then build
newer, more powerful widgets
and gadgets
with which
the user interacted.
With your mobile devices,
I believe we need
to go one step further,
which is,
"user interaction is cool,
but wouldn't it
"be even nicer
if your device could do
"what you wanted
and show you what you wanted
before you went
and interacted with it?"
Because you are not
taking your phone out
of your pocket in order
to interact with the phone.
You're taking the phone
out of your pocket
to interact with the world.
You're taking the phone out
of your pocket
to find out where
to go have dinner.
You're taking the phone
out of your pocket
to go talk to your buddy,
not to interact with the phone.
So this is really
what is cool
about building innovative
user interaction
on mobile phones.
You are really focusing on,
"how shall I minimize clicks?
"How shall I minimize
screen switches?
context switches?
And how shall I have the user
get his work done?"
So let's go to the next
section of the slide.
So as a case study,
I'd like to take you through
two things that we've built.
You can actually see
Youtube demos of this
on the eyes-free
Android channel.
What I'd like to work--
We will do demos
during the session,
but what these slides
are really about
are sort of walking
you through the thought process
that went towards coming up
with these solutions.
Because I, personally,
when I see someone
show me a solution
they've come up with,
I often find the process
of "how did you get that"
more interesting than
the eventual artifact.
And hopefully that applies
in this case too.
So the problem
we were solving--
The specific problem that
we solved last September
was I wanted to start using
the Android phone
as my primary phone because
I believed
that that was the only way
I would build
the right
user interaction environment
that matched my needs
and the needs
of eyes-free interaction.
So the Android phone
is a nice, smart computer.
It's all of these things.
But the reason you first
put it in your pocket
was because it's a phone.
And many of those platforms
I had had before it
did a lot of things,
but they were so complicated
to use that I stopped making
phone calls with them.
And to me,
that was a problem.
So the first thing
we worked on was,
"How can I use
the phone eyes?"
So this is
an interesting question.
You could have sort of pandered
on the interesting problem here
and said,
"Well, it has a keyboard.
Pull out the keyboard
and dial it."
But that's inconvenient.
And as I said,
if I had done that
I would have joined the club
of people walking like this
and I promise you I would
definitely walk into things
if I did that.
So the question was,
"How do you actually use
that touch display
and do things with it?"
Common wisdom said,
if you cannot see,
you cannot use
a touchscreen.
And so the way you sort of
debunk myths like that
for yourself is to go ask
the question, "Why?"
You know, two-year-olds
ask the question "Why?"
And succinctly,
I think we as developers,
geeks, and scientists
need to ask
that question
the whole time.
So why is it
that most people believe
that you must be able to see
in order to use a touchscreen
to use an on-screen keyboard?
It's very simple.
How do you use
a touchscreen?
There are two atomic acts
involved
in activating
an on-screen control by touch.
You need to look
at the screen
in order to locate
the control.
Then you need
to go push it
and get some feedback
for having pushed it.
Clearly, if you're
not looking at the screen,
you need feedback
at both levels.
And the showstopper that most
people stumble on is,
"Well, you can't see it at all
in order to see
"where the button is if you're
not looking at the screen.
Therefore,
you cannot use it."
So let's ask
the "why" question again
like a two-year-old,
right?
Why do you need
to see the button
to know where it is?
Well, because the button is
positioned in a fixed place.
You need to know where,
dummy.
Well, why is it positioned
in a fixed place?
And the answer
immediately emerges.
Well, it needn't be
in a fixed place.
Somebody chose to put it
It was in a fixed place,
right?
So the other way
to think about it is
rather than you
looking at the screen
in order to find
the keyboard,
what if the keyboard came
and found your finger
when you put your
finger down?
So the opposite
of absolute positioning
is relative positioning,
and that's what we've built.
So this is what we call
a stroke dialer.
We came up with
a very simple idea
saying wherever you touch is
the center of the phone keypad.
Okay?
Put your finger there,
it's five.
There, it's five.
That's five.
Ah, but now you know
where five is.
Well, if you know
where five is,
you know where two is,
you know where one is,
you know where nine is.
So this very simple insight
of asking the why--
irritating "why" question
many times
gave us
a very simple answer.
So the next time your
two-year-old asks why,
don't yell at him.
Answer the question and he'll
probably find out something.
So I'll let Charles
do a quick demo
of the stroke dialer.
What is interesting
about the stroke dialer
with respect to its feedback
is that it actually
gives you auditory feedback
in terms of sound cues,
it speaks the number,
and it also vibrates.
And all of those
are synchronized
and that's a big,
big win with respect
to doing the
user interface correctly
because it gives you
a whole sense of realism.
So this is an interesting thing
about the real world, right?
If I take a coffee cup
and put it on a table,
it goes "click" and it gives you
force feedback on your hand.
The table resists.
If, for instance,
the table didn't resist,
you would drop the cup.
If you didn't hear the "clink"
when you put the cup down,
you would feel something
was wrong.
And the same applies
to building
a touchscreen interface
where you're doing
auditory input and touch.
male computer voice: Nine.
One. One.
Raman: So obviously you heard
the auditory output.
You even heard
a little bit of vibration
because it's
on a wooden table.
So this is sort of
an interesting exercise
with respect to doing
a stroke dialer.
And later on in the talk,
Charles will actually show you
how you can actually
use this as an overlay
in your own applications.
So the thought process
is nice.
Showing you the thing
working is nice.
But being able to plug it in
to your own applications
is really the icing
on the cake,
or, you know, the icing
on the Swiss chocolate
or whatever you want
to call it.
Let's rip to the next section
of the slide.
At this point,
you're probably saying,
"Yeah, yeah, big deal.
But nobody dials
phone numbers anymore."
It is true.
You don't dial
phone numbers anymore.
You use your contact manager.
So how do you do
a contact manager
for an eyes-free model?
So this time you're going
to do letter input
instead of numbers
and obviously
you have to sort
of maintain contacts
to all kinds of things.
Some of the problems
we actually danced around here
because of the way Android
works with a cloud
and it's actually quite cool.
Some hard problems
are best solved
by getting rid
of the problem.
That's what you will see
with respect
to editing contacts.
But let's talk
about modifying
the stroke input idea
in order to input letters.
Now there are many ways
of using a touchscreen
and using your finger
to input letters, right?
There's Graffiti.
There's many, many versions
of Graffiti.
All of these systems you can
actually think of as two steps.
I'm going back
to the intention.
You have an intent
you're communicating
to the computer idea.
You want to come up
with an encoding
that is easy for the computer
to process.
This is why Graffiti
was invented
as opposed
to human handwriting.
So you want a thing
that is easy,
unambiguous to recognize
by everybody.
And you want to come up
with a mapping
that is easy for the human
to remember, right?
So I could come up
with a set of strokes
that are very easy
to recognize for the computer,
but required extra learning.
And, you know, early days of
the Apple Newton
showed us that people
just give up very quickly.
They don't learn a new system.
So we don't claim that
what Charles and I
are showing here is the world's
best encoding system for--
from strokes to letters.
But it is a system
that's worked for us.
And it actually works
particularly well
on the Android screen.
So I'd like
to show you that.
So this time, instead of
thinking of the phone keypad,
think compass directions,
magnetic compass directions.
So you have north and south,
east and west,
northeast, southwest,
southeast, northwest.
So I intentionally
said those in pairs.
There are eight of them.
Let's think of them
as four pairs of two each.
Now, you know,
you sort of think about it,
there are about 26 letters.
You know, eight, four.
Do the math, you know?
Let's say we put
eight letters on each
of these--for each
of these pairs.
And let's sort of
think circles, okay?
So let's think circles and since
this is a Google IO talk
at a Google auditorium,
let's think of it
as four colored circles.
Like sssign the four
Google colors to them.
Let's put letters "A"
through "H" on the first circle.
Let's call it blue.
Let's put the next eight letters
on the second circle.
The next eight on the third
and the next eight
on the fourth.
Now we normally have eight
compass directions.
There are four sets,
right?
Let's use the north and south
pair to enter a circle.
Let's use the east and west pair
to enter a different circle.
Let's use the diagonal screen
to the outer sides.
And the way the circle dialer
that we've done works--
The circle keyboard,
whatever you want to call it--
The way this guy works
is that you stroke
in any of the eight
compass directions
and that gets you into
one of the four circles.
Then you trace along the circle
till you get to the letter.
Now since we can enter each
circle in two places--
so the north or the south
or the east or the west--
think of it as entering either
at the top of the circle
or the bottom
of the circle.
This will all get obvious
as Charles
starts showing it to you.
So, Charles, let's show them
how we do an "A."
So remember the first circle
has "A" through "H."
So "A" is just an upward
diagonal stroke.
male computer voice:
Phone book.
female computer voice: "A."
Raman: Now notice that it said
it in a woman's voice.
It finalizes it when
he picks up his finger.
male computer voice: "A."
Aarthi Raman.
Raman: It's also
in his contact manager,
so it's actually
jumping to contacts
that start with an "A,"
but we'll talk about that soon.
So "A" was very easy to do.
Now "A" through "H"
are on the same circle,
so to do a "B,"
he would do an "A"...
female computer voice: "A."
Raman: trace along...
female computer voice: "B."
Raman: and pick up his finger.
male computer voice:
No contacts found.
Raman: See, he doesn't have any
contacts found at that letter.
Now--So "A, B, C, D, E, F,
G, H."
Now once you get used
to this input system,
to do an "H,"
you obviously don't go around
in a circle like a dork.
You actually
go the other way around.
So you go from "A"
to "H" in one stroke.
female computer voice: "A, H."
male computer voice:
No contact.
Raman: Now supposing
you wanted to do an "E,"
you could start at "A"
and go all the way around
from "B" to "C" to "D"
to "E," but we don't do that,
because remember
we have two points
at which we can
enter the circle.
So we enter directly at "E."
So the downward diagonal.
female computer voice: "E."
male computer voice: "E."
No contacts found.
Raman: So now you see the "A"
through "H" circle working.
Similarly, going up
or down gets you
into the second circle
that has "I" through "P."
Just scroll down.
female computer voice: "I...
J, K, L, M."
male computer voice: "M."
Mom cell.
[laughter]
Raman: So now this
is what we are using
to filter our contact list.
So we did the simple thing of
you do a letter
that jumps you to the first
contact with that letter.
You do one more letter.
We sort of take
that as additional input
and continue filtering.
And so the thing
you realize with this
is that you get
to your contacts
in about one or two gestures.
Each letter of the alphabet
is no more
than three steps away,
right?
So if you wanted to do a "C,"
you go "A, B, C."
So that's about the longest.
Because if you want
to do a "D,"
you go to "E" and
go back to "D."
So you get very good
at this very quickly.
And the color coding sort of
helps you to learn it,
but once you learned it,
you do it
without looking at all.
And the contact filter thing
is very, very nice,
because you can really filter
through your contacts
very rapidly with this.
Flip to the next slide.
So finally, the part about
the best way
of solving some hard problems
is to get rid of them.
How do you edit contacts?
It's best not to edit contacts
on the phone.
Nobody does that, right?
What do you do particularly
if you want
your friend's phone number?
You say, "Could you call me so
I get it in the call log
and I can add you there?"
That's right.
That's why we all do it.
Well, because Android talks
to the cloud,
there's an even better way
of doing it,
which is just to use
your Gmail contact list.
So I actually edit
all my contacts online
and it shows up
on the phone.
That's great.
And if I meet people
at events like this,
then I do the age-old
click of,
"Oh, please give me a call and
I'll add you to the call log."
So that's how we do contacts.
[indistinct]
Chen: Oh, sure.
And actually
it's my turn now.
Raman: Exactly.
That's why I wanted a word.
So from here on,
we'll sort of go through
all the technologies that we use
to implement all this.
I'll let Charles talk
about the TTS library,
the gesture library,
and all kinds of good stuff.
Chen: So, hello, everyone.
So I just have a quick question
before I start.
How many of you saw
the keynote yesterday
and the TTS demo?
Awesome.
Now how many of you here,
you know,
are interested
in writing TTS apps
or have written a TTS app
or, you know,
currently working on one?
Wow, this is fantastic.
So I just want
to say thank you.
You know, developer interest
is very important
and the interest that has been
shown to the TTS library so far
has been one of the factors
in getting TTS
into the base platform.
So give yourselves
a round of applause.
[applause]
And so with that being said,
you know, we don't--
It's going to come in Donut,
but for right now,
if you want to get a head start
and start working
on talking applications,
the APIs will be very similar.
We're actually involved
in working
with the Android team
importing it.
And what you're gonna get
is you're gonna get
a head start and you can start
developing your apps
and start playing
with this by using
our currently released
text-to-speech library.
And that's what
we'll be talking about
for the rest of this session.
Raman: So on these demos now,
what you hear is eSpeak.
But as developers,
go ahead and write your code.
When Donut comes out,
you will just
get a better voice
and all your apps
will just sound much better.
Chen: Okay.
So let's get started, here.
So the TTS library.
So this is something
that enables developers
to create Text-To-Speech-enabled
apps that talk to users.
The way it works
is that as a developer,
you go into Eclipse
and you compile
against the library stub jar
that we've included
on our developer's site.
And Text-To-Speech
is an Android service.
And we have
a TTS class
that acts as a wrapper
to take care
of all the messy
I-Binder stuff.
So you just create it
like a regular Java object,
you just do a new TTS,
and you can start using it
by doing tts.speak
and some text.
And part of the beauty
of having this as a library
that gets reused is that
the TTS library can be updated
without you necessarily
having to update your app,
and it also
enables multiple apps
to share the same
TTS service.
So the user doesn't have to
install it multiple times.
And once it goes in a platform,
then everyone just gets it.
So let's look
at some of the--
you know, some of
the main features that we have.
There's a very simple,
easy-to-use speak function.
So it takes the string of text
that you want spoken,
a queuing mode, whether you want
to speak immediately
and flush any text that's
currently waiting to be spoken,
or if you want to queue it up
and then some param--
some additional parameters
that you could have.
There's a stop call,
because otherwise
your application
may talk and never stop,
which would be
kind of annoying.
And you can also check
the current status--
whether or not
it's currently speaking
so if you're
trying to synchronize
some on-screen display
you can synchronize it
with where you are
in the speech.
And we also have methods that
let you synthesize to a file
so you can get an audio file
that, you know,
you can set
as your ringtone or something.
And, you know,
you can specify a language
so you can
do translation apps,
talking translators,
all that good stuff.
And the current behavior
of the Text-To-Speech engine
is that it will
automatically
prompt the users
to install the TTS service.
And if it's absent you can
set it to just fail silently
so it won't
bother the user,
or you can just have it
automatically redirect the user
to Market,
where they can download
the current TTS service.
For more information,
and, you know,
to check out
our source code,
this is all open source,
free, so please take it
and we look forward to seeing
what you can build with this.
And you'll see the url there.
eyes-free.googlecode.com.
And that's where you can
get all the source,
all the jars,
everything.
And so with that,
let's...
I'm going to dive
into an example of this
later in the talk.
I'm going to talk about
the gesture library right now,
and give a brief overview
before I start on the code--
on the coding tutorial.
So the gesture library--
that's what Raman
had discussed earlier.
You know, he had shown
the stroke dialer
and the contacts
input method.
And so both of those
use this gesture library
that recognizes
very simple strokes.
Now my Mac
is not behaving.
There we go.
Okay.
So this is an overlay
that watches for touch events,
so it will tell you when a user
has touched down the screen,
when they're moving
around on the screen,
and when they
lift their finger up.
So you know which position
they finished at.
And it will tell you
the identified gestures.
So you can actually
see the gesture
as the user is making it,
or you can just get
the final result
of, well,
the user stroked
the diagonal up.
And this exposes
the same UI
as the stroke dialer
to the user.
And we implemented this
as a custom View,
and this is
a custom transparent View
that you can layer
on top of your applications.
And so this means that,
you know,
you can do your UI
however you want to,
and you can just
overlay this on top,
and it won't have any effect
in how your view renders.
To use this
what you have to do
is you have to implement
a GestureListener.
So you create a
TouchGestureControlOverlay,
and you start with
a FrameLayout as your base View.
So what you would normally
have as your View,
you set that as the first child
of your FrameLayout.
And I have an example of this
later on in the talk.
But if you do that,
then what you'll get
is you'll be able to layer this
TouchGestureControlOverlay
as a child
on top of that,
and then you can
enable or disable the gestures
by adding or removing
that View from your FrameLayout.
And so with that,
let's jump into
the heart of this presentation
and look at a tutorial
with some real code.
And so I'm going to demonstrate
a simple music file browser.
How many of you here
have gone to Anddev.org?
It's a website with developers
and code examples. Cool.
So they actually posted
a very nice FileBrowser tutorial
when Android
first came out.
You know, how you can
explore the SDCard system
and look at
what's there.
So we took that, and we show how
in just a very few lines of code
you can add both Text-To-Speech
and gesture controls to it.
So this is a very simple
music file browser.
It lets you browse directories
on your SDCard
and play MP3 files
that it finds there.
And you play the music
by just clicking on that file.
And the directory path
is the first entry.
If you click
on the directory path,
then it just
cycles through
all the MP3s you have
in that subdirectory.
And as you scroll
through the list,
you get some
tactile feedback,
so you actually feel like
you're moving through a list.
And so now I'm going to explain
how to add spoken feedback.
So you first start off
by creating a TTS object
in method onCreate.
And this will cause it
to run the Text-To-Speech
as part of its
initialization.
And then you can add some
application-specific logic there
so that your application
comes up talking.
So let me just switch over to
Eclipse and show you the code.
Okay, so this is
the music file browser--
the base music file browser
before we added anything to it.
And let me actually
demonstrate that first
before I go any further
in this talk.
So it's the first
music file browser here.
And you see
the contents of my SDCard.
I can scroll
through it.
And, you know,
nothing's talking,
but, you know,
it works.
I can go to MP3s.
And, you know, I can play
a couple of popular songs.
Like this.
[Rick Astley's
Never Gonna Give You Up]
Okay, enough of that.
Raman: That's popular?
Chen: [stops music]
Chen: I-I think it is
popular on the Internet.
At least on YouTube.
[laughter]
So--Okay, so let's see--
Now let's see if we can
make this a little bit better.
A little bit
more interesting.
And, you know, let's see
if we can make this talk.
So...
Okay, I need to switch
back to my Mac, here.
And--Okay, so what
you just saw here
is the basic
music file browser.
And this is just the tutorial
that was on Anddev.org
that we modified a little bit
to handle the playing.
So where we made
the modification is down here.
And we added
a toggle playing function.
So--So we did that,
and the other thing is we added
some tactile feedback to when
you scroll through the list.
So if you look at here
we have this--
I'll track by that.
Okay, how's the font size
for everyone?
Can you guys
see it okay?
No? Okay, let me
zoom that a little bit.
Okay, so now we're
better on text size.
Okay.
So here is where we added
our vibration control to it.
Aside from that, it's the same
basic file browser.
So let's see,
how can we add speech to this?
So here is the version
where we've added speech.
And I've helpfully
set break points
so I can find all the places
where I added some code.
There's not
that much code,
so the break points
are pretty useful.
So we added a line to--
here to create a TTS object.
Up here.
And then we have
a TTS initialization method.
This will get called
whenever the TTS is created.
And so you see when we start it
we helpfully announce
that, hey,
music file browser started.
And then the OnCreate
method of your app.
We have now
this TTS--new TTS.
And we set the initialization
listener to "ttsInitListener."
So this--this is what causes
our Init function
up here to get called.
And then--then it's
pretty simple, right?
Now, you know,
earlier I'd mentioned
we had this
vibration feedback
for when you scroll past
certain items in a list.
Well, so we can
actually latch
the Text-To-Speech functionality
on top of that.
So instead of just vibrating,
play will be vibrated
and we spoke the directory
or the music file name.
Well, that's what
we ended up doing.
So if you look
down here...
Ta-dah.
So there we have
"tts.speak(filename.substring,"
and we just
speak it there.
It flushes
right away.
And you can--
As a result, you can hear
what you're scrolling to.
So--so let me
demo that version.
computerized male voice:
Music file browser started.
Chen: So there.
So now you'll always know
when it actually started up.
And now I can
scroll through.
computer voice:
Up one level.
Raman: On your own phone
it won't talk so loudly.
Chen: Yeah,
it only talks this loudly
if you put it
next to a microphone.
computer voice:
D-sim, download.
D-sim, dow--
espeak data, MP3s.
Chen: Okay.
Raman: The voice you hear--
that is eSpeak,
and as I said, this will--
this--you know, over time you'll
have multiple voices available
to you that you can choose.
computer voice:
Up one level.
Portal, Still Alive.mp3.
[Portal's Still Alive]
[laughter]
Chen: Okay, so cool.
Huge success, right?
So--Okay, so let's kind of see
what that actually meant.
So--so you saw
all the code that I added.
Those couple of lines--
That was--that was it.
Really, to get
TTS working.
And see, if you--
if you actually
go back and count--
So all--so these slides
will be available,
and our code
is already available
on our Eyes-Free
Google Code project.
So I challenge you all to go
back and download this code--
check it out,
and actually do a diff
and count
the number of lines.
Because the diff--
You're gonna find
that it's really just
13 lines of difference.
So adding--And this includes,
you know, import statements,
just, you know, generic,
boilerplate things, right?
Like adding a closing brace;
that's a line.
So it add--We only needed
to add 13 lines of code,
and we added full Text-To-Speech
functionality
to this
music file browser.
So--so this is--
this is nice.
You know, now you have
a talking music file browser,
but what if you
wanted to use this
while you were jogging
or something, right?
It's not going to be
very convenient
for you to jog
and try to use the track ball.
That's going to be
a little bit difficult.
It's probably
much easier
if you could just do
some gestures on the screen;
scroll through
what you wanted.
So--
Raman: You don't want
to jog with the track ball
because the track ball
will keep jogging
and nothing
will ever be stable.
You really don't--
Need something else.
Chen: Exactly.
So--so let's add
the gesture input method
to the music file browser.
So as I mentioned before,
the gesture overlay
is a transparent overlay,
and you can just over--
you can just put it on top
of your existing content views.
And this won't interfere with
your visual appearance at all
because, hey, the whole thing's
transparent, right?
So you add this
to handle user input,
and we're going to add
two very simple controls.
So we're going to say
when you tap down on the screen
that's play or pause,
and if you want to gesture
towards the right,
that means you want
to just cycle
to the next track
in that directory.
So--so this is the type of code
that you have to write.
It's fairly simple.
You start off
with a GestureListener.
man: [indistinct]
Chen: Ooh, whoa.
Thank you.
Sorry about that.
Okay, so yeah.
Anyway,
you didn't miss much.
It was basically just--
just code here.
Thank you.
Can we get--give this guy
a piece of chocolate too?
[laughter]
Raman: I got it.
We could be like dog kennels,
handing out gifts for bugs.
Chen: Absolutely, absolutely.
Thank you.
Okay, so--So yes.
GestureListener.
So we're going to do--
We're actually doing
something very simple because
we're just going to do tap
to play or pause.
And we're going to do
a stroke to the right
to cycle through
the next thing.
In both cases,
we actually don't care so much
what the user is doing
as they're making the changes,
so this "onGestureChange,"
we can leave it empty.
We don't really
have to implement it.
And then--All we care about
is "onGestureFinish."
So if they finish
their gesture in the center,
then that's a tap.
So we do the "play/pause music"
code here.
And if we see that the gesture
is a gesture to the right,
then, hey,
it's a stroke to the right.
That means
we should go ahead
and play the next track
in that directory.
And we don't really care about
when they start the gesture.
'Cause, you know,
we're not doing anything
that's timing-related here.
Now, to put this
into your app,
What you have to do
is you should
take your main content View,
put that inside a FrameLayout,
and then make
your FrameLayout the main View.
So this way you can
switch your overlay on and off
by just adding
or removing it.
And then to toggle it,
then, it's pretty simple
because all
you have to do to--
if the overlay is active
and you want to disable it,
you just do a simple
"removeView," and it's gone.
And then you can
touch the screen
and interact with it
as if you didn't have gestures.
And then if you want
to turn it back on,
you just do "addView,"
and suddenly now
you get this
transparent overlay on top,
touching it becomes
gesture inputs,
and you won't trigger anything
in the View underneath it.
So let's look at what this--
what this code looks like, here.
So here is
our own gesture code.
This is what I had just shown
in the slide earlier.
And...
As you see,
we didn't need to worry
about gesture changes
or gesture starts,
we just look at how
the user ended their gesture;
determine what they did.
And the main change
that we had to do was over here.
So over here, notice how now
I've created a myFrame object.
That's a new FrameLayout.
I'm adding the "myList,"
which is the content view,
to that FrameLayout,
and then I'm making
this gesture overlay--
Which I'm currently
not putting it in yet,
because I didn't want
to start off in that mode.
And then I set
my content view for my app
as the FrameLayout.
So--And so then the FrameLayout
manages everything else.
And finally I had to add
an "onKeyDown" event
because, you know,
sometimes you do want
to switch between the two modes.
You might not always
want to be in gesture mode.
For example, it might be nice to
be able to just click down
on a directory
to drill down into it.
In that case
you don't really
want that to get
treated as a tap,
so to switch back and forth,
I'm using the "Menu" key.
And using a Menu key
you swap it on, swap it off.
So--so let's look
at this final version, here.
And this time
I'll remember to switch.
Yay.
All right.
Go back
to the home screen.
computer voice:
Music file browser started.
Chen: Okay, so now we have
the music file browser.
So it started off
without gestures,
so I can actually
just click on the screen.
I click this.
So that worked.
Now let's say I want to just
start playing using gestures.
And I don't want to care
where I'm tapping.
computer voice:
Gestures activated.
Chen: Gestures activated.
Okay, so let's stroke.
[Portal Still Alive]
Raman: It worked.
[Rick Astley
Never Gonna Give You Up]
[applause]
Chen: Thank you,
thank you.
So now, if you look at what--
what that actually amounted to,
again I challenge you to go back
and do a diff and verify this,
but when we did this,
we added about 40 lines of code.
And that was it.
So adding 40 lines of code,
you get this gesture thing,
and it just
works for you.
And so with that,
I will hand it back to Raman
for the conclusion.
Raman:
Okay, thanks, Charles.
So as Charles said earlier,
all these libraries
are open source as part
of the Eyes-Free project.
Feel free to use it.
Even better, feel free
to contribute patches.
Contributions,
innovations.
In conclusion, I believe
user interaction research
in the mobile space--
especially for devices that can
see, hear, and sense the world--
is a very, very exciting area
of research that's opening up.
The mistake we shouldn't make
is to try and take
the 30-year old GUI
from the PC
and push it
into the mobile device.
I think that would be
a disservice to all of us.
I think these
devices can be--
do much better
at sensing our intent
based on what they sense
of the world,
what they sense
of our actions,
of our history of actions.
And they also have many, many
ways of grabbing our attention.
From the type
of work I do,
speech output
being my primary--
sort of the biggest thing that
I am interested in and work on.
Voice on Android, as you heard
yesterday during the keynote,
voice output is going to
get a lot, lot better
thanks to our friends
from Zurich.
So in conclusion I think there's
a lot more stuff to build here.
All of you even have
the phones to build them on,
so come hack with us,
and let's have a great time.
And at the end
of the day,
let's build technologies
and user interfaces
that bend those devices that you
have in your hand to your will,
as opposed to you
having changed--
having to change how you work
and play to match those devices.
Let's flip
to my final slide,
which is my usual Q and A slide
that's my dog flying a 767.
So if that's possible,
anything's possible.
[laughter]
Chen: So yeah.
So now we're gonna
take questions.
So please don't be shy.
We don't bite.
Raman: We only
bite chocolate.
Chen: Yes.
man: I have two questions.
Chen: Sure.
man: Is it easy
for a handset vendor
to change the voice?
I think the voice
is pretty...
Chen: So--so that's
going to be a Donut question
because that's going to ship
with the Donut platform.
And what I would like to point
out there is for right now,
the Text-To-Speech library--
it's just a library
that you can get off-market.
So you can get
any TTS you want off there.
And we do want to make it
a pluggable TTS architecture
So you could use
our default TTS voice,
or you can use some other
TTS voice that you prefer.
But our default will sound
pretty darn good.
man: Okay, and the second
question is
is there any
global settings menu
that application vendor
can check the settings value
and ultimately enable
these kind of features?
Chen: So I think you're
a little bit confused, sir,
about enabling
this feature.
Because the way it works
is this is an API.
So this is going to be
just like, you know,
using the accelerometer on the
device or something like that.
The user doesn't
have to explicitly
turn on the accelerometer,
it's just there.
You just code to it, you write
a function call and it works.
Yes.
man: How would you inform
the user
of this functionality,
especially the gesture
functionality as being there,
in a consistent way?
Raman: That's--
that's a good question.
You're asking the question
of discoverability,
and that question
is, in general,
one of the hardest
in the mobile platform.
So all of you holding those
Dream G1 V2 devices,
do you know that holding down
the "Home" key--
a long press on the "Home" key
brings up a list of six--
the last six used
applications?
I discovered
that today,
nine months
after having a phone.
[laughter]
So you ask a good question.
Do I have an answer to that? No.
I believe, though,
that over time we need to--
we will come up with gestures
that are sufficiently intuitive
that people use it.
There will be
some learning involved,
there will be some
word of mouth involved.
You know.
And if it is
really useful,
people will over time
discover it and learn it.
That's the best
answer I have.
I don't believe the PC desktop
GUI answer to this is--
which was, you know,
"everything shall be
made discoverable
by cluttering the screen"
is going to work, unfortunately,
in the mobile space.
So if you're--
That's a good
research question to answer.
We don't have
an answer to that.
Chen: Yes, Clayden.
Clayden: Where do things stand
with rooting synthesized speech
out over the--
a phone call?
Is that now possible?
Raman: Routing synthesized
speech out over a phone call.
I do not believe--
I do not believe I know
the answer to that yet.
I could check
on that for you.
Clayden: Okay, thanks.
Chen: Yes.
woman: Hi. Are you also
working on Speech-To-Text?
Like, is it possible
to input speech?
Chen: So currently
in Cupcake
there is a reco API
that you could use.
Raman: There's a reco API.
You can--Over time you'll also
be able to use an IME
that is speech-input.
That--that work is being done
by many people at Google
including the people
who do Voice Search.
So that
is being worked on.
It's not typically us.
woman:
So that's not part of Donut.
Raman: Sorry?
woman:
Would that be part of the--
Raman: The Voice Search part
is part of Cupcake.
woman: Okay.
Chen: It's already out there.
woman: Okay, cool.
Thank you.
Chen: Anything else?
Okay, well, thank you all
for coming out here.
It was great having you.
Raman: And please
send us your feedback.
[applause]
Have a good day.